не витрачай юрич не тим кривавих шляхів на
майдані вухо та віза традиції добуваються
числа не мітингу відразу. ок сила що
бути провиси ви
цілі віч і він наділив і марш свободи та і
планується активізувалася а
та мало у будинку організації kenshi та до них
на думку хату будуть у Росію посилені на
гаїті коштує євро ж не шукаю терпіння
українці на стоп край і люди ви пощастило
ось буде і на бул йти проти
російські ЗМІ відразу ж розбухнути
кадри скринька однак social особисто якщо
ж не показують частіше за нас троє українців
важливіше вікна та програм ульте не властиво
раніше розривання та апатія фронтової c
саме у спокої калі калли радикалізації
6 статті можна сказати про налаштування рулити
або
загалом взятій ситуацію від перед
євромайданом теж летиш на їхньому блоці
провісників що будуть такі масою
виступи маса та виступи була замотана
тільки з тим, що було не було наказано
асоціації з європейським союзом від нього
шоу було побути а студентів та цілі та й
душу бурлоф піци маку на струмені в 3
адже років 74 сотки українців кожну
ситуація в Україні змінилася вона йоржі і
адже ви намети сотки стягнути заміни
positive ну-ка мало катував і розповімо про
зал стань або змінилося на краса ївши
талас на зміни на краще
був і за значенням щодо образу
знатності крайон з медицини армії
вівса та шос було в економіці була осінь
на ту ж негативно
українці схожі часто самі не знають, кому
вірати
досвід його нею квітневого міжнародного
інституту соціології ви його миску
проторити ось сенти ти в чиїй наших
шляхів про світом маже 45 сотки
1 приватного смажити винними у вінні на
донбасі та україні та росії 22
сотки поважає шуменський процес підривають
ікри та москва 9 500 kit оцінити майдан
одна приватна державна пара воріт yett
народну революцію ти мені менше то до
розлучення вниз на донку соціологи
привід для українців з кути його за
ви щури акрилової бідні всі українською
революції їх не спонтанність стенд
верхньому сьогодні та на майдані
мобілізувати ми можемо будь-який момент у
тринадцятому уроці залі був аморфний
масу та мобілізовано що свобода за раз
просто влада у нас нові на мої кістки 10
але instant усама заощадження і не знаю
наташа навіки до відривали пам'ять до ecu
відкривав і на діяльному від кордону
страви і звичайно нагнітає
Ціни можна так це над пенсіонерами
вселяти вона трубить ніками
1 год руссо братам народ прокинувся
подавати народ і ти до президента імідж
та Верховна Рада Президента ніж win with
sweet його все за шкірою пункт свої
передвиборчі кампанії in the beach of за
два дні за два тижні
води ми вчимо нібито на добро, що з'явилося
від українців на вулицю їхня їжа сивого дати
щур у політайте вона баку але метті так
було завжди
і цін на думку соціологи мої статті
сигналом для нинішньої влади